[Music]
you know in recent times we've
encountered so many new fake made up
genders that you may think you can no
longer be surprised by the latest
innovations in the gender market and
perhaps this one will not surprise you
but it does point us towards
some insights that are worth reflecting
on limbs of tick tock brings this to our
attention the uh the hottest thing going
on right now
fresh out of the oven it's called cake
gender
listen
okay i would describe zeno genders as a
gender that could not typically be
described with terms such as masculinity
femininity neutrality androgyny things
like that it's more of not how you
relate to a particular gender
experience but more of how you relate to
things
for example cake gender um
i know
a few people who personally use this um
it's typically described as them feeling
light and fluffy or sweet and warm and
it's not something that you could
typically describe with the terms
masculine feminine androgynous etc
another example of cake gender would be
if someone feels like they have
different layers or flavors to their
particular gender
cake gender
now i have no idea why
first of all if you're going to choose a
pastry related gender you would identify
as cake which is by far the most
overrated and most frequently
disappointing dessert item
i can see maybe high gender cookie
gender brownie gender
the last one may be problematic you know
from a racial perspective i don't know
then again those other genders i just
made up probably already exists i mean
exist inside some troubled tick tocker's
head at least these are actually tells
us examples of xenogender
and i'm told by
non-binary.wiki that xenogender is a
quote non-binary gender identity that
cannot be contained by human
understandings of gender more concerned
with crafting other methods of gender
categorization and hierarchy such as
those relating to animals plants or
other creatures things
yes someone who is zeno gender a term
invented by somebody on tumblr in 2014
by the way
is so complex and deep and poetic that
they can't be contained by human
understandings
they transcend thought and reality and
coherence
the xeno-gendered individual cannot even
relate to mere mortal human beings like
you you and i she is beyond them above
them like a goddess floating in the
clouds
she cannot be compared to any gender
instead she can be compared to cake
now if you're wondering
about the pronouns for someone who is
cake gender they are and i looked this
up
cake cakes and cake self
so
here's an example sentence
cake went by cake self to the bakery to
get a cake to celebrate cake's gender
transition to cake
after the doctor replaced cake's
genitals with cake so that now cake can
live his cake and eat cake while being
cake
hopefully that clarifies things for you
of course i'm being unfair i mean i'm
making cake gender people seem very
extremely insane when they're merely
just extremely insane after all the lady
on tick tock says that a cake-gendered
individual does not necessarily identify
as a cake but rather identifies with
cake
she says that someone who's cake gender
and she knows a few people more than one
who identify this way
it's really someone who feels that
they're light and fluffy and warm and
sweet
now this is confusing to me because the
times when i feel fluffy
like i did last night after eating too
much indian food
those are precisely the times when i do
not feel light at all so i don't really
understand that
be that as it may
this actually reveals something quite
clarifying and important about the
pronoun phenomenon i think
what it shows is that when these people
talk about gender and pronouns
what they're really talking about if
they're talking about anything at all
is personality
now i'm skeptical that anybody who
identifies as a baked good could really
be warm and inviting but if they are
that's their personality it's
personality not gender personality your
personality is not your gender it's just
your personality
you don't need a pronoun to describe
your personality that's not what
pronouns do
you don't need a gender to describe your
personality that's not what a gender is
these are all three separate categories
of things
now if i were to identify myself with a
food item that encapsulates my
personality
i suppose i'd have to identify as like
the shoe leather that you would be
forced to consume if you've been
stranded at sea for seven months and
your food stores have run out
but rather than claiming that i am shoe
leather gender it'd make more sense to
just say that i have a rigid tough
distasteful and unpleasant personality
and that would make a lot more sense and
also be true
now when you come to understand this
fact about about the gender and pronoun
mania gripping our culture it begins to
make a little more sense still not very
much sense but a little bit more
as we've covered many times much of this
is born from sheer narcissism these are
people who spend far too much time
thinking about themselves analyzing
themselves inspecting themselves
categorizing themselves explaining
themselves to
themselves they've kind of rolled their
eyes all the way back into their heads
and now they spend their whole lives
looking back into the caverns of their
mostly empty minds
that's one important element of this but
the other is that
these people suffer from confusion i
mean all sorts of confusion obviously
but especially category confusion
they conflated the personality category
with gender
and in so doing they've essentially
erased personality entirely
i mean now there is no personality no
variation within types
that's why these people they notice they
never talk about their personalities
they only talk about their genders
their gender type because there are only
types
they see gender as a filing cabinet with
a thousand drawers and each part of them
goes into a different drawer each part
is cataloged and labeled and categorized
and when they're done divvying
themselves up there's nothing left
there's no room for personality
ironically in their obsession with
identity they've left no space for an
actual identity
they've not only categorized themselves
to death but they also have turned each
part of themselves into a gimmick a
costume
everything authentic has been lost i
mean if you're a woman who also happens
to be sweet warm and inviting
that's a wonderful thing i mean you
should be that sort of person
we need people with that personality in
the world there are too few of them
right now
but the moment you turn that into its
own gender
you've just made your sweet authentic
personality into a weird
fetishistic charade
you've made a parody of yourself
and you've lost the thing that
would have made you distinct and
interesting and valuable to society
this is the consequence of the
genderification of everything
we lose
what was distinct and personal and good
and unique
and we end up with
cake gender
and that's why cake gender
along with cakes themselves actually
are today
hey listen
hit the subscribe button do it right now
i demand it and i thank you for your
compliance it is somewhat appreciated